c'est vrai c'est vrai vous êtes fidèles
voici soi même ou à soi-même mais c'est
mauvais signe quand on dit cette
situation non mais vous poser comme
question bien sûr bien sûr je suis fils
habite au pas du tout le moment de dire
autre chose pourquoi que c'est bon c'est
pas le moment d'y retourner je suis
fidèle bien sûr bien évidemment je suis
comme bernard fixot mon fils
n'est pas bien
c'est sûr elle a dû trouver
de quoi quoi tout va bien vous êtes un
célibataire non j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
je n'en parlerai pas mais j'ai en
attendait si tu l'avais rencontré
quelqu'un oui mais dans la rue mais à
trois semaines et vous allez parcours
mais je suis en courant dans les jeux
c'est bien vous qui savez tous
d'habitude
mais tout va bien il faut laisser un peu
de temps comme l année à la fac et là en
quelle année à la fin j'ai pu c'est
amusant non mais alors c'est qui non on
veut pas ça rend le nom non comme non
non non c'est quelqu'un que j'avais
rencontré ya très longtemps je vous êtes
en passe de trois semaines peut-être
masse on s'est embrassés oui ça y est on
se sont
[Musique]
quand même fait nous regarde et vois son
mec fait saillie c'est ton
et une l1 en plus il définit trois
semaines et intérêts j'ai toujours et
commence à tromper tabac au bout de
trois semaines qu'est ce que c'est au
bout de trois mois ouais je dis pas ça
pour vous aujourd'hui
[Rires]
ouais franchement fois et donc alors
c'est quoi non parce qu'elle en a
vraiment je suis fidèle bien évidemment
non mais donc ça fait trois semaines ça
fait trois semaines cet égard il faut
que ça avance et messieurs
c'est une copine que j'ai connu il ya
très longtemps
là dans la fredzone on peut devenir dans
l' île aux zones à c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour voix et caudry les
ramasser alors oui donc rien n'est qu'à
moi c'est un peu tôt oui mais je suis
bien qu'annoncée sur le net ça je sens
qu'un petit truc
allez plus de alors juste elle est plus
au niveau de l'âge et les plus chères
audrey beinheim géraldine où il appelle
à la mise à niveau des côtés d'isabelle
dix jours est vrai les femmes mûres oui
mais là c'est ses murs oui mais hors les
murs oui les femmes
qui sont près d'un mur des prédateurs
ces poissons deux ans la belge encore
mais 52 ans donc ça compte oui c'est ça
les jo mais c'est vrai à huawei et genre
c'est l'amour fou non on n'en est pas
encore là mais on s'entend bien déjà
donc on va prendre le temps doucement
elle s'exclame anne de vous monter sur
tes grands chevaux
de deux étages et
merveilleux mos espa que le siffleur
voilà ce que j'aime beaucoup nicolas
willot il en a chié ouais il en a chié
nicolas c'est quelqu'un et ça doit
d'ailleurs c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un
qui a non mais c'est vrai ce qui est
énorme a chié dans sa ligne et la de
savoir qu'il est à nouveau heureux ont à
nouveau presque amoureux à nouveau en
train de construire de bâtir tout built
by halle berry est franchement très
belle action ça veut dire qu'il ya les
papillons dans le genre
mais j'ai réfléchi et la non non non je
plaisante
c'est quoi ces hobbies et ses hobbies
les hobbits votre oreillette au hall à
l'annonceur pas l'humour
[Applaudissements]
où vas tu la donnes tout à fait mis au
paddle dont on la connaît pas de tulle a
cogné aux pyramides dans ton club de
sport c'est bien vous la connaissez
c'est alors que je la connais alors non
mais vous n'êtes pas permis tous les
jours mon bureau je suis souvent les
bons mais en tout cas non je suis sûr
que je sais
je suis sûr que c est ce qu elles
échappent ainsi ont démarré votre
émission est
venu voir son aise qu elles aient chacun
oui allez chami
elle est mince dit la vérité peut-on
grande hall est normal non elle est bien
réelle et plutôt mars elle est grande
elle est gros mais qui vous pensez les
grandes me [ __ ] un bordel l'embellie
salée elle est grande oui à les grands
opéras et j'ai vu une meuf de sardan
grandes mains chacun il n' ya qu' je
veux pas d'abord c'est pas mal moi
quoi à ce serait bien pour pernik ok je
suis sénégalais moussa sow
non mais c'est incroyable non mais je te
le dis c'est beaucoup quoi c'est vrai je
sais pas je pense que c est le plus
ancien je te dis que si on démarre elle
est mise à une photo alors excuse moi
c'est l'émission de bernard montiel
berne à ce que tu veux qu'on continue
interrogé par
[Applaudissements]
la fota et un nikos et d'amour c'est
mignon s'il avait visiblement envie de
nous en parler de bras c'est vrai oui
bien sûr mais en
beaucoup mieux maintenant vous sont
graves vraiment je suis heureux c'est
vrai on ira manger à la pizzeria avec
patoche
jamais dans mes parents aussi
by isabelle aussi non mérité en famille
mois ci nous inviter escales moi aussi
je viendrai avec guillaume tell être non
non et non avec
des fidèles maintenant
[Applaudissements]
on était devenus coupé c'est bon j'ai
dîné avec lui un avec qui il part ni
goff on était plusieurs véhicules
blindés attendait non alors c'est un
club des déplacements
c'est tous les dimanches là si on était
au match du psg mène donc j'étais avec
une amie et pernikoff bon ami
extrêmement mal à l'aise c'est qu'il a
parlé à mon ami mise et or c'est quoi
tes mobile dans la vie bat elle je fais
de la boxe et sahil 7 arrive souvent de
faire défoncer est dépendant à quitter
l'aquitaine immédiate
elle a déposé une main courante sur un
an
et
quand vous avez tout match avec
guillaume genton oui je suis au match
jeu mais gmail et nicolas pernikoff il
doit déchanter pouvait tuer ce qui fait
le
général poste au bond
qu'est ce qu'il fout mais cible
exactement c'est besoin de toi mais
c'est messi qui est sorti
j'ai parrainé pourquoi ils ne sortaient
pas d'ailleurs échoué qui bougeait pas
même pas brillant alors j'adore mais si
mes choix qui peut bouger pas beaucoup
sur le terrain moi j'aurai beaucoup plus
vite la main ça m'a dit que tu pouvais
pas beaucoup non plus
[Applaudissements]
je le défends messi parce que c'est un
très gentil garçon parekh le pêcheur
jaunies est très très contente de messi
le club voilà que les dirigeants parce
qu'il est c'est un amour son entourage
c'est vraiment très sympa il n'y a aucun
souci cela raconte pas il a rien du tout
la grosse tête il paraît vraiment que
c'est un mec extraordinaire un média pas
marqué deux buts en trois matches et qui
joue pas vous satisfaire
mais il a mis la mire transversale hier
et il avait il il a fait un bon match
mais on n'est pas là pour parler de
messi on est là pour parler de nicolas
pernikoff bechiri merci en tout cas
nicolas mas est heureux pour vous
séjournez surcoût de bonheur ben merci
maman et j'espère que comme valérie avec
patoche vous irez voilà loin qu'est-ce
qui a battu nantes je souhaite aussi
[Rires]
ce n'est pas l'image et découvre des
choses j'imagine pas aimer le foot
j'imagine pas que ce soit un bon coup
aux pages imaginer
des coûts des trucs mais là c'est sûr
mais voilà je suis pas fan de foot a
alors mais vous vous êtes toujours
dépressif